[موسيقى]
طبعا
الصمغ هو عباره عن كربوهيدرات اللي هو
مواد كربوهيدراتيه
بالاضافه لبعض البروتينات السكريه وهو
غذاء الشجره نفسه اللي هو اللي بيتكون من
امتصاص الماء من التربه بواسطه الجزور
وبيتم تصنيع الغذاء بتاع الشجره في
الاوراق وبالتالي بيتخزن في الخلايا
المختلفه في
اجزاء الشجره وبيمر عبر اللحاء وطبعا
كمزارعين وقاعدين في المنطقه دي والمنطقه
فيها اعشاب وبعد ما ننتهي من حصائل الحصاد
بتاع الزراعه
الاعشاب لانه اعتباره عايد لنا تاني عشان
نقدر نقدر نشوف شغل جديد من
طوقه وابعث 45 يوم الانتاج تاني بعد كل 15
يعني يعني كويس جدا يعني بعض الحصاد انت
بتكون الحصاد ده قاعد تنتهي في حصاد تاني
الحاجه المفروض تحصل وما حاجه سهله يعني
اي حاجه في الادويه
لكن راى منه اهله
بعد ان تعرفنا على طبيعه تكاثر هذه الشجره
وطرق الزراعتها وانتاجها وحصادها وتحضيرها
لموسم الانتاج الصيفي نتجه الى حيث يتجه
المنتجون والتجار الى سوق المحصولات
الاكبر في الولايه وهو سوق محصولات الابيض
[موسيقى]
دي البدايه يا جماعه بتاعه المزاد في سوق
محصورات عاده المزاد بيبدا بالصمغ العربي
عندي باقي المحاصيل السمسم الفول الخام حب
البطيخ السنه مكه
التجار بالنافسه في بعضهم بعد عم نرتب
السعر المناسب في المسير
المتوسط الصمو حاليا الليله ب 38,000